we are now only a couple of weeks away
from Apple's massive September event
where they'll finally launch the iPhone
15 lineup and in this video I have 10
new leak updates to share with you guys
that I've collected since the last
version of this video so let's jump
right into leak update number one
according to unknowns 21 who was the
first leaker to share an actual photo of
the bottom of the iPhone 15 Pro and its
USBC Port he has now given us a huge
leak showing the iPhone 15 colors that
were tested through various development
stages we have a new pink which could
end up being a rose gold or a blush gold
we have green blue yellow potentially
some form of orange and a black or
midnight color and he does mention that
there could be of course potentially
more colors but these are the ones that
he has seen now getting into leak update
number two we have a major leak that has
been blowing up all over Twitter and the
tech World various sources including
Majin Buu kasutami-san and the
lippilipsy have been showing tons of
photos and videos of brand new
never-before-seen color matched braided
USBC to USBC cables which are supposedly
going to be coming in the box of every
iPhone 15 model we can see various
colors that totally look like they could
match the new iPhone 15 colors including
a fully blacked out cable that even
includes black USBC connectors on the
ends offering color match cables could
create a new trend where people get
excited about USBC and I can totally see
Android phone makers following in
Apple's footsteps with these color
matched cables and to make it even
better we got reports that these new
cables could be even longer 1.5 meters
instead of one on the current cables
which everybody is gonna appreciate on
top of that I've personally found that
the new braided cables from Apple are so
much more reliable and durable than the
old ones that would Fray and get ripped
up and damaged especially since these
new braided cables are unlike the ones
that come with the iPad Pro and iMac by
adding a new strain relief layer to help
durability so I'm honestly super excited
for these now on to leak number three we
have something that nobody is gonna
argue against and that's a rumor
pointing to at least some new iPhone 15
models supporting faster charging yes
apparently the charging speed will be
going up to 35 watts of Maximum charging
compared to 27 which the current 14 pro
Max can accept now that doesn't seem
like a huge deal but it's actually 30
percent more wattage now I do want to
stress that just because it says it can
hit 35 Watts doesn't mean it'll charge
at that rate the entire time because
it's normal for batteries to charge
quickly at the very beginning with a
very empty battery and then as they get
hot and full the rate does slow down
which is very common for Apple because
they care about charging and battery
health and yes I will admit that the 14
lineup does have some battery health
issues so hopefully Apple solves that
with the iPhone 15 lineup now moving on
to leak update number four we just got
perhaps the weirdest update ever we just
got a new leak from nine to five Max
sources claiming the Apple will no
longer be selling leather cases for the
iPhone 15 lineup which sounds crazy
because they've been selling them for
many years and it's a staple of Apple's
premium accessories that they sell
because it comes with the indented Apple
logo on the back which is something that
other case makers legally can't do now
this new leak is really weird because we
recently saw a bunch of leaks of leather
Apple cases coming for the iPhone 15
lineup however shrimp Apple Pro did say
that he's hearing the same thing that
there will be no leather cases and same
with Dan Rue on Twitter now my personal
guess is that Apple will for the first
time be creating a vegan or synthetic
leather case that's more eco-friendly
which would also increase Apple's profit
margins so it makes total sense now with
that said I don't think the apple is
going to be completely cutting leather
cases from their offerings because
people just love them so much it's just
technically not going to be leather
anymore it's going to be thick now
before I get into leak update number
five I've got to show you today's
sponsor which is G's cable which is a
revolutionary patented cable that stops
hackers and their tracks by including a
button that will physically turn off all
data transfer capabilities so that when
you charge your phone in public it'll be
unhackable and then when you need to
transfer data just hit the button again
and you're good to go go it comes with a
choice of lightning and USBC to fit any
device so order yours today by using the
link in the description below to keep
your data private for update number five
we are getting more and more rumors of
price increases on the iPhone 15 lineup
but don't worry they're only for the Pro
Models just the other day on August 22nd
digit times came out and said that
Apple's pro and pro Max iPhone 15 models
will go up in price by between 100 and
200 US dollars which is a big deal this
of course adds to previous reports like
back in July when Barclays analyst Tim
long said that the 15 Pro could start at
10.99 and the pro Max could start at
11.99 or even 12.99 and yes even if
Bloomberg reported that apple is
considering raising the price so now
with all of these reports I think that
we can say for sure that the 15 Pro
Models are going to get more expensive
with no doubts at all moving on to
update number six we could have a
potential explanation for this 200 price
jump on the 15 Pro Max model and that
came recently from Apple insiders Andrew
O'Hara who says he's heard from multiple
sources that Apple will be rebranding
the pro Max model into the ultra model
to try and differentiate them and
potentially start giving more features
to the ultra like the Periscope zoom
lens and more this idea was originally
mentioned by Mark German last year but
then he came out and said that apple is
going to delay the ultra branding until
the iPhone 16 lineup but who knows maybe
Andrew is right we're just gonna have to
wait and see and in my mind I think this
switch totally makes sense because
currently the pro Max name is kind of
dumb and confusing especially since we
have the M2 Pro and M2 ships over on the
max side so combining both of those
names is just kind of weird now for leak
number seven I'm sure you've heard all
about the action button coming to the 15
Pro Models and I think with this new
report we can finally confirm it for
good nine to five Mac has been digging
in the iOS 7 beta 7 update and they
found completely new haptic feedback
patterns that are meant for when the
user enables or disables silent mode
which is something that wasn't there
before that's because in previous
versions of iOS there was only a quick
haptic feedback setting for when the
iPhone goes into silent mode but never
for when silent mode is disabled which
is proof that we should get a new action
button this actually adds to previous
findings from Mac Rumors within beta
code showing multiple options for what
can be assigned to an action button
click so with that said we can now all
100 percent expect the action button to
be real and come to the 15 Pro Models
now for leak update number eight I've
got to go back to that color matched
braided USBC cable leak basic apple guy
on Twitter just showed off renders of
color matched air pods which is a great
idea since it would lead to a huge boost
in airpods sales so if Apple was ever
gonna sell airpods with different colors
the time to do so would be right now and
I have three great reasons for why for
number one apple is already working on
USBC airpods cases to coincide with the
switch to USBC on the iPhone 15 lineup
and yes we have leaked codes and models
for that and everything else so this
will happen 100 on top of that we also
have rumors of the color matched braided
cables so it would be the perfect
opportunity to Market color matching
your iPhone with the cable and the
airpods as the next new trend now apple
is already selling their 24-inch iMac
with the color matched braided lightning
cable color matched keyboard and color
matched Magic Mouse and they're doing so
with success and no production issues so
that could have been a test run for
color matched iPhone cables and
potentially even airpods and for the
final reason which is the biggest one we
actually had real leaks of Apple testing
color matched airpods cases in the past
so what if they were testing those in
preparation for the iPhone 15 launch now
you should still take this with a grain
of salt but it's definitely a
possibility now on to number nine we had
a huge leak of the iPhone 15s USBC Flex
cables and components that show that we
could be seeing Thunderbolt data
transfer speeds on at least one of the
new 15 models according to charger lab
who was able to see an integrated
circuit that's called commonly known to
support Thunderbolt speeds that right
there is a huge deal because that would
make the iPhone 15 Pro Models the first
mainstream smartphones to support
Thunderbolt and its 40 gigabit per
second transfer speeds which is massive
and would definitely help sell more Pro
Models and finally for leak update
number 10 we just got confirmation from
Tech Reeve on Twitter that the iPhone 15
Pro Models will be getting multiple chip
upgrades to improve efficiency
ultimately leading to better battery
life he confirmed that the DDI chip or
the display driver integrated chip will
now be built on 28 nanometer node
technology compared to the previous 40
nanometer so while the display panel is
going to be the same on the new iPhone
15s it should use less power on top of
that he also confirmed that we're
getting a Next Generation U2 Ultra
wideband ship built on seven nanometer
Tech instead of 16 so once again more
efficient and and he also confirmed
Wi-Fi 6E is coming to the 15 Pro and
finally a massive upgrade to 15 watt
wireless charging with third-party
Chargers with the new G2 standard and
yes shrimp Apple Pro even replied and
said he confirms all of those points so
there you guys go those were 10 new leak
updates for the iPhone 15 lineup so if
you're inside so you guys go so there
you guys go those were 10 new leak
updates for the iPhone 15 lineup so if
you're as excited as I am subscribe
above and check out one of those two
videos right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]